foreign
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I present to You
The divinely Chosen ruler of
King Philip
ah this is boring I can't believe father
is making us pot for our own food Philip
quiet father brought us here to teach us
a valuable lesson can't you see today
you must embark on a hunt to develop his
rulers of this realm you too must
participate and learn the craft yes sir
what should we catch one hair each do
not let me down
[Music]
shouldn't be too hard right one hair
each wait freeze do you see one quiet
not so hard is it Jules
how much further are we going to have to
walk just give it up Jules the rest of
the hairs ran away just a little bit
further I'm sure there's one around here
somewhere afraid you'll let down father
it's late we should head back where the
darkness will follow us
you are correct after all that was my
hair now I've got two and you have done
father will be so proud please give me
one just to carry back hmm no
I must show father that I am as capable
to rule as my brother are you dare to
return the father with only shame
carried in my hands wait a minute my
hands that's it do you remember what
fada taught us about holy combat you
mean the game King's play for the hair
for Father's blessings I challenge you
to rock papercraft blades
I don't want to
[Music]
agree if a person of the same status
challenges you you must
fix princes you cannot refute the call
those are the rules fine
and if I win
what do you desire how about
your soul
my soul for a single hair but of course
he knows he can wager so high father's
judgment looms over us we're twins I
know father loves us equally but with
each passing lesson I feel myself
sinking further from his good graces but
what good is fatherly Love In The Eyes
Of Love Eternal without the holy spirit
that finds us I'll be worthless doomed a
roam an empty Planet as an apostate when
Rapture strikes what say you brother
hmm
one two three shoot
you lose come on the servants must be
preparing A Feast for the great hunters
let's go home
[Music]
Jules are you unwell you're so pale and
haven't eaten a thing
Philip what has happened to your brother
he made the young princess falling in
my son
foreign
on this day the one year anniversary of
my coronation I bring forth a token of
peace
the Barbarian King himself this token of
Peace means their attacks will come to
an end
look at them so complacent and happy
ruling is so easy peace War what's the
difference anyway now they're in the
palm of my hand ready to obey my every
order
the jewels do my eyes betray me Philip
you knew I would return to claim what is
rightfully mine
greetings
brother
the mark on your head huh still
recognize me I'm no longer the kind soul
I once pretended to be I've tried for
one whole year in the order of the
crossblaze it's my moment no turning
back
I challenge you who no no you dare
refuse to call the holy combat you must
accept
do you not remember brother we are no
longer of the same status I am now a
king and you are not I need not accept
challenges from peasants but by all
means go challenge one of the servants
maybe they'll entertain your delusions
one year later and you're as cowardly as
ever Mewtwo King rejects the call for
Holy combat only when it's true
[Music]
after him at once do not let him Escape
I want him in Chains my brother
embarrasses me on the anniversary of my
coronation no less Phillips I know this
night was important to you but you saw
what EXO has done to him what do you
expect hmm he's your twin after all and
he's been through a lot you have a
kingdom to rule not a score to settle ah
Elizabeth my love you keep the gates to
my heart open the people would Suffer
Without You you flatter me my love let
us head home we've had enough revelry
for one evening
[Music]
father's grave he taught me everything
but now that I stand Here on filled with
questions
father I need your wisdom I have never
questioned your love for me but I begin
to question the love of our creator
Faith force is my hand to lose every
battle have I been cursed since that
rueful day when my boy is folly turned
into Cosmic sin have I not proven myself
yet wait if you really dare guide me and
I will follow
thank you
[Music]
if I must be a king to challenge him
then so be it I shall not see him again
until I wear a crown of my own
I must find a kingdom in need of a king
[Applause]
I King doto have come to avenge my
kingdom you have forced my subjects into
submission but I will not submit you
rate my lands and then Paul your spoils
up for a token of Peace the only piece
you brought to my people were quiet
praise
my duty to personally share your vision
of peace with you
I keep the doors closed tonight King's
orders
hi who goes there
I am a guest of the king
no further guests allowed tonight King's
orders oh really I have written
permission right
here huh
oh
[Music]
got him I am Professor sent out to sea
Let The Winds of eight carry me to my
enemy and let my enemies lust bring
their gaze upon the holy symbol of death
which I carry by my side
oh blimey that was my last match
need a hand
light oh I suppose so thank you
a barbarian in the castle stop you're
under arrest
fine put me in jackals
the Barbarian King Elizabeth look me in
the eye what's happening let your eyes
gaze upon me and nothing else my eyes
casing for none but you my lord yes but
if you've altered for even a moment now
it will spell your doom
upon you King Philip gaze into the
symbol of death and Die With Honor does
he think I'll give in to his little
trick ha
please never face the minds like mine
Elizabeth sweet Elizabeth gentle and
pure
and her mind are wide open how else
could her smile be an effortless Delight
to all who are graced by her presence
like a butterfly she dances upon the air
but also looks like a butterfly can be
blown off course by even a gentle breeze
Philip your ancient not just fortified
your mind like no one else I've met
while the iron walls you've built to
protect your psyche May hold now I see
there is a crack through which I can
slip and to whom might this threshold
alone I hope it doesn't slip from my
palm and break
those are my mothers we have many sacred
heirlooms do not waver and whose ashes
might these be hope they weren't anyone
special
Elizabeth my eyes
your iron will is very impressive King
flip
tell me is your will strong enough to
stop a blade
[Music]
oh
you got her
who is the best
now
final gays fall upon your dear Queen
I should have never underestimated him
by luring Elizabeth first he's put me in
an unwinnable scenario that puts my very
Humanity at stake if I follow my heart
and look at my faithful wife therefore
behold in the symbol of death I'll be
luring my conscience away of mental
Fortress I've worked so hard to build
but I'm afraid that by not looking it
will lay the final Stone in the brick
while protecting my psyche and my mind
and heart will become impenetrable I
won't be able to let anyone in and ever
again including Elizabeth forever I will
lose my last shred of humanity open your
mind Philip let it all in
[Music]
your attacks will have no effect on me
Barbarian
my instincts remain razor sharp but your
wife you must look have you know hard I
know your faith and the discipline you
swear by you cannot lay a finger upon me
if I do not look and my faculties are
stronger than your lure you are
powerless against me
God put on your blindfolds and restrain
this intruder
I Wanna Dance covered in Iron never to
be seen again
what have I become do you remember
[Music]
McDonald's
hi peasant oh really do you like battles
you love them all right well we want to
have a big battle in episode three but
we don't have enough troops oh no
oh no I do you can enlist on Corridor
digital.com Corridor Digital Dot what
Corridor digital.com and if we get
enough troops well well we can make
episode free
and have a big battle oh that sounds
great
oh wow I love this outfit I got a
handsome lad
[Music]
hey you beautiful viewers in celebration
of this video we've just released a
limited edition anime rock paper
scissors 2 t-shirt and long sleeve tee
I'm here now what the heck this sale is
going on for a limited time only and
will never be offered again so grab one
now at quarter Digital Dot store and uh
if you're subscribed to the website you
get 15 off your order so head on over to
quarter Digital Dot store while you
still can
I said the last thing no I said the last
thing
[Music]